what this is like getting married you
can't say hurry up describe them and why
you don't want to date them and then
pick and say their and give them a
chance to change your mind okay well can
I can I say some stuff okay yeah that
work all right oh my my
God oh my
God
oh show me the proof that's how he got
out of it dude he show shut the up that
was his secret weapon
what the
flying you look really cool in this you
look hella cool dude you're not a part
of this what I know but what is this
somebody explain to
me but I know it was a weapon and I have
used it greatest episode is this you
it's not don't tell me there's more than
one please guys Anthony won't let us
sell these shirts